ted all right today is national red wine
days anyone excited for that in here
yeah can i hear it
let's take a sip everybody with the
local at the district at green valley
randy you are the co-owner of the local
how you doing i'm doing well thank you
for having me what does this day mean to
you well then you have a wine bar every
day is a celebration
but
today we get we we have an opportunity
to uh you know have people come and
explore some of the wines red wines that
we have and obviously white wine and and
rose and you know we they we give people
yeah absolutely all the drinks now i
hear that the local you kind of pride on
the fact that you can go off the strip
for that classic wine experience at the
local we're very proud of our design
we have an open airy intimate experience
um
as the weather cools down you'll see our
glass garage door open pictures right
now and uh it's just a it's a really fun
experience great place to to uh to be
yeah well you're the co-owner so i can
imagine that you got good vibes so let's
talk about this spread this beautiful
spread what's on the menu for national
red wine day what are we pairing with it
everything's on the menu we have uh
charcuterie cheese meat
you pair that with a nice red wine or a
white wine
you have chicken salad we have some
wonderful sandwiches a lot of shareable
stuff so when you come out with your
friends or your networking for business
you can pair a nice bottle of wine with
a lot of snacks right so what would you
say since we are celebrating
specifically red wine what do you think
pairs the best with that i'm a big fan
of our
meat and cheese board here
it's it's really uh it just
the way that we've developed it the your
palate just everything intermixes it's
really a wonderful treat with your red
wine or or anything else and these are
not pickles what are these called
those are pickles they're they're
actually called pickles i thought there
was a fancier name for it nope that's
not fun they're so good
okay and you guys have monthly wine
tasting right yes we do that we actually
uh we've we've just implemented this new
our new wine tasting and it's been going
on very very well
you can come out and taste new world
wines old world wines
from french and spanish regions
and it's just a great time you know you
can do date night you can network for
business we we uh we really love our
monthly wine tastings and
a lot of fun a lot of fun at the local
the local are you are you there
sometimes when people catch you uh yes
good i try to hide in the back though so
i know thank you so much man you guys
check out the local happy national red
wine day and we will be right back on
las vegas now